let's bring in laura trump former senior
advisor for the trump campaign
and we have a big announcement she is a
new
fox news contributor welcome to the
family laura
yay thank you so for the folks at home
that don't know you they
they see you they know that you're
married to eric and y'all have
these two beautiful children but tell
them a little bit about your life where
you grew up what you're like
and what you plan to do here at fox well
i'm so excited first of all to be
joining the fox family i sort of feel
like i've been an unofficial
member of the team for so long you guys
know it was kind of a joke
over the past five years i would come
there so often that the security guards
were like maybe we should just give you
a key
so to be to be a part of the team i'm so
so excited
but i grew up in north carolina i grew
up in wrightsville beach north carolina
my family still lives there and i moved
to new york about 14 years ago and
that's when i met my husband eric i
never expected to be part of a family
like the trump family certainly never
expected to have the incredible
opportunities that i've had
one of them obviously being now to be
part of the fox news team
so i'm so excited i'm so honored and
really looking forward to what's to
come indeed and although i read just a
couple of days ago you were still
considering
running for senate in north carolina
yeah well
fox has been uh very generous with me
and they have said look if that's
something that you ultimately decide to
do they're going to work with me
on that front and make sure that
everything all the rules are followed
and we do everything properly so
thank you to to the fox team for
allowing me to have
you know the possibility that that's in
the future so i still haven't officially
steve made a decision
but hopefully sometime soon all right so
let's move on to one of the reasons why
uh you're valuable is your your position
on the big stories of the day
you know during the campaign no one was
really talking about illegal immigration
to a great degree because
the border was pretty settled the big
debate was on the wall and it was
financed
they took that money they're not
spending it they took the wall that was
built they're storing it
or destroying it and now we're seeing an
all-out invasion
on our southern border they even have to
take guards from the north and bring
them down to the south
here's jen saki trying to explain our
way through why it's okay for kids to
come
at this point in terms of allowing
access
to border patrol facilities for
reporters you are being less transparent
than the trump administration
well first of all chris the trump
administration was turning away kids at
the border sending them back on the
treacherous journey
or they were ripping kids from the arms
of their parents we're not doing that
i we are committed to allowing cameras
into the border patrol facilities
absolutely treacherous journey ripping
uh ripping kids from parents
yeah i mean totally ridiculous obviously
none of that was the case
in fact we had the most secure border
under my father-in-law under president
donald trump
that we have had in decades and i think
the best thing possible is to
discourage people from making that
really dangerous
awful journey north through our southern
border the problem is
that the biden administration has said
well if they come
we'll take you in so guess what's going
to continue to happen you're going to
continue
to have all of these children you know
flooding our southern border
it is so sad it is so hard to watch but
we have to get this under control this
is not fair to these kids
uh it's not fair to americans who are
footing the bill now
86 million dollars to pay for hotel
rooms for illegal immigrants people that
are breaking our law
coming to america we are paying 86
million dollars for hotel rooms it is
totally
unacceptable um but you know what we
don't expect to see that change because
this seems
almost like it's part of the biden plan
sadly well you know laura as we look at
these images
that ted cruz i think took over the
weekend
inside that facility at donna texas they
are horrible and of course when your
father-in-law
was president they referred to
conditions much nicer than that
as kids in cages but you know what i i
don't think
the people there and i don't think the
democrats for the most part
mind those particular overcrowded
conditions because they know that
everybody
in that facility is going to wind up
getting released into the united states
they are being processed
next stop any town usa so it's just the
price you have to pay
for them to get into the united states
yeah well and it's total hypocrisy you
bring up a great point
the way they covered this under the
trump administration versus the biden
administration
is total hypocrisy where is the outrage
from the folks on the left
where is aoc down there doing a photo op
crying
in front of a wall because i have news
for her it is much worse
right now than it ever was under the
trump administration yet
it has been crickets from those folks
and i think it tells a very scary story
they know that they have millions of
illegal immigrants coming to america
they are trying to change our voting
laws they are hoping one day
that all of these folks can go in and
not and vote with no id because that's
one of the things in hr1 that they're
proposing
these are their new voters and it is a
terrifying prospect if we let everybody
just free flow over our southern border
guys
we lose our country it is a very very
scary thing we've seen going on yeah i
know your father-in-law worked really
hard to get the vaccines
and that was operation warp speed but
democrats
joe biden and his administration refused
to give him credit
watch this there was no national
strategy or plan for vaccinations
in many ways we are we're starting
from scratch
two months ago the country this country
didn't have nearly enough vaccine
supply to vaccinate all or ever near all
of the american
public does former president trump not
deserve
any credit on vaccines making the
progress that was made and we've said
this publicly that was made on these
vaccines was
a herculean incredible effort by science
and by medical experts
and certainly we have applauded that in
the past and we're happy to applaud that
again but then there's dr anthony fauci
he's taking credit for it listen
when i saw what happened in new york
city
almost overrunning of our health care
system it was like
oh my goodness and that's when it became
very clear
that the decision we made on january the
10th
to go all out and develop a vaccine may
have been the best decision
that i've ever made with regard to an
intervention as the director of the
institute laura what's your what's your
response to that
well it's almost hard to watch that
without laughing and with all due
respect to dr anthony fauci
it was president donald trump and
operation warp speed
that allowed us to get to this point
right now where we have
so many millions of people vaccinated
across the country we're headed towards
herd immunity
i have been in the presence of my
father-in-law when he would get a call
from the folks that were developing
these vaccines and they would say we
don't know if it'll be ready and he
would say go back to work
we need this vaccine we need a safe
effective vaccine
to get america back up and running so i
don't know
sort of what fantasyland dr fauci was
living in but it was under
the direct direction of president donald
trump
that we got these vaccines and thank god
we did because america
is finally starting to come back i think
people are starting to feel like
this nightmare might be over but i give
full and 100
complete credit to president donald
trump so so laura what do you think can
you give us an idea of what's going on
in mar-a-lago we know the president gave
an impromptu speech at a wedding over
the weekend
uh had a tux on and he started talking a
little bit about politics
we also know that he's considering going
down to the border he said he's been
asked to go
in the next two weeks is he getting is
he get you getting the sense that he's
getting set to
to run again well
i'll leave that announcement up to him
if that's something that he ultimately
decides to do but
it's really hard i think to see sort of
the disaster that has ensued since joe
biden took
office uh you know whenever you set
things up so well
and stay silent so you know i know the
border patrol
wants to have my father-in-law come down
to the southern border i mean
he was the person that really turned
things around down there and and really
got us you know in such a better spot
with illegal immigration in america
he he did give a speech at a wedding
eric and i were there over the weekend
he was so happy to be there but look he
he is doing what he feels he needs to do
he's standing up and continuing
to speak out for the 75 million plus
americans
that voted for him he has not forgotten
about them
they will not be left behind by
president donald trump
and quite frankly it's one of the
reasons that i'm so happy now to be part
of the fox family
because i hope every single day i can
represent them uh here on fox and and
you know make sure that we are
transparent because quite frankly
the biden administration is not we need
to call them out went for their failures
my father-in-law will continue to do
that and i will continue to do that here
on fox
that's right if people missed the very
beginning of this segment
laura trump has joined us she's now the
newest member
of the fox news family welcome to the
family laura
thank you guys so great to be with you
at the christmas party